tonight on Tim cast IRL Maryland man
fatally shot by police quote while
asleep in his bedroom conspiracy or just
warrant gone wrong words gone wrong so
we have uh what's up everybody a lead
story we have for you was requested by a
lot of people who started looking into
it we got some articles pulled up it's
about a man named Duncan lamp who was
killed by police they were serving a
warrant and witnesses say that he was
just sleeping and the cops start firing
through the door I don't know they're
like wearing masks or something it's
Heather it's like a crazy story yeah
I don't know I don't know if there's too
much in the way of like legit reporting
on what's really going on we got a
couple stories but this really does fall
in line with a couple things well I
should say with one real thing it's
these red flag laws right where they
basically serve a warrant without you
knowing and they're like we're coming to
take your guns and then people are like
no you're not and then they get killed
it's happening a lot because the people
who said my cold dead hands yeah amen
yep so welcome to the show everybody I
am Tim Poole this is Adam what's up
everybody we got to Lydia Lydia behind
the scenes we are working on the camera
for everyone and if you would like to
have your comment read in the super chat
just super chat and we read through them
we try to do our best sometimes we got
to pass through we read as many as we
can and don't forget to subscribe hit
that like button and share and share
make sure you tell everyone we are
really awesome people please do yeah say
say you must come and and watch this
amazing show especially that's so jesus
guy yeah so jesus he's a vegan but
you'll like him you know that's funny
because they're not a [ __ ] vegan right
but know that there are people saying
like I once thought that soya Jesus was
a soy boy but then I realized is
actually a soy Chad and I was like all
right there you go soy bro yeah yeah so
we got it we have a bunch of stories
we'll see we get su but we were talk
about Atlantis as well because we're
talking much the other day and I think
to get away from the coronavirus and
politics we're like let's just talk
about some weird stuff it stuff's fun
you know I like weird stuff there's
there was a viral video on YouTube where
people were claiming they discovered
Atlantis I loved it they were like this
is where it is and then jerks were like
no this is not where it is and so we
have the debunk article we're gonna
I have something that I want to be true
and believe me I'll talk about it okay
when we're talking about the subject
well so this this first story I read the
article that the null can lump one and I
you know it's it's a similar story we
hear a lot so I didn't know if there's
anything you know like I don't know how
to actually like address what's
happening people think it's like some
grand conspiracy somebody commented in
the super chat this a guy was like
working on some kind of encrypted
program or Bitcoin or something like
that yeah I haven't seen anything but it
feels like if he was they would probably
want to keep it under wraps you know
whatever was but I'm sure someone out
there knows and just doesn't want to say
anything because if this happened to you
know the person they know that was
working on it yeah
there have been a handful of people who
have died under mysterious circumstances
indeed
suicide etcetera I know someone
personally who have been working on some
crazy stuff oh I don't know if you want
to bring that up yeah that's another
that's another subject that will light
up it falls in line with this a little
bit if this is the case in it and it
kind of is involves a very very high
profile individual it really does what
is he talking about isn't everybody all
excited right now what could it be
yeah so let's let's just go into this
and yeah it comes out if it comes along
alright here we go the Guardian this is
story from March 14th Maryland man
fatally shot by police while asleep in
his bedroom Montgomery County police had
duncan socrates Lemp confronted officers
as eyewitnesses gave contrary account
they report a Maryland man who was shot
and killed by a police officer was
asleep in his bedroom when police opened
fire from outside his house an attorney
for the 21 year old man's family said on
Friday the man's girlfriend was also
wounded the Montgomery County Police
Department said in a related news
release Duncan's socrates lamp
confronted police and was shot by one of
the officers early on Thursday but renee
sandler an attorney for lemp's relatives
said an eyewitness gave a completely
contrary account of the shooting
she said police could have absolutely no
justification for shooting lamp based on
what she has heard about the
circumstances the facts as I understand
them from eyewitnesses are incredibly
concerning the warrant police obtained
to search the Potomac home Lemp shared
with his parents and 19 year old brother
not mention any imminent threat to law
enforcement or the public lumps
relatives said in a statement released
by their lawyers nobody in the house
that morning had a criminal record the
statement said any attempt by the police
to shift responsibility onto Duncan or
his family who were sleeping when police
fired shots into their home is not
supported by the facts a police
department spokesman it did not
immediately respond to statements from
the family or their lawyer not
surprising the department's news release
said tactical unit members were serving
a high-risk search warrant around 4:30
a.m. when one officer fatally shot Lemp
police detectives recovered three rifles
and two handguns from the home Lemp was
prohibited from professing from
possessing firearms police said
detectives were following up on a
complaint from the public that length
though prohibited was in possession of
firearms that really said without
elaborating san sandler said the family
believes police fired gun shots not a
flashbang or other projectile from
outside the home including through lems
bedroom window while he and his
girlfriend were sleeping nobody in the
home heard any warnings or commands
before police opened fire there is no
warrant or other justification that
would ever allow for that unless there
is an imminent threat which there was
not the police release said facts and
circumstances of the encounter were
still under investigation
prosecutors from neighboring Howard
County will review the evidence at the
conclusion of the investigation so I
guess we will wait and see I have a
feeling this will get buried definitely
it feels like it's gonna get buried I
mean it's interesting that they were
just let me scroll up a little bit it
says detectives were following up on a
complaint from the public that's yes
they're going that that's the reason
they went and got a warrant because the
public was complaining that he had no
way dude and the something was
complaining who knew a guy with no
criminal record was not allowed to have
a weapon exactly and then just so you
know wait why was he prohibited to have
weapons it doesn't say that either it's
like what and the biggest thing if they
were if they had a confrontation with
him that means they saw him and they
would have shot him how did his
girlfriend get wounded that wasn't wired
into the window with that that doesn't
make any sense to me like what were they
just be like like just shooting in the
general direction just like no they're
trained to like aim at the person okay
and we had so the end they saw he had a
gun and said put it
and he didn't so they would shoot at him
why would his girl be there with him if
she was sleeping would she follow him
right stand right behind him during this
whole thing well so we have this story
it's from the American Conservative this
is really interesting because we're
starting to see you know the left for
the longest time has decried police
brutality and a lack of accountability
yeah now especially with red flag laws
conservatives are also saying basically
the same thing and then it is
interesting to when you see there's a
lot of sheriffs and police who are
saying they refused to serve like
confiscation orders don't anything like
that so we'll see how far that you know
whoever it is who wants to push these
laws will see how far they take it yeah
but this story from the American
Conservative says the mystery deepens
over the pre-dawn police killing of
Duncan Linton well that's an interesting
thing - the pre-dawn 4:30 a.m.
Shelvin boom you know we hours the
morning and is it to catch them sleeping
because they they did and they were
wearing masks yep so like and they as
that eyewitness said they didn't
announce themselves they didn't like
this is a we're serving a warrant thing
so they were woken up if you're in the
making up at 4:30 hearing someone
breaking into your house without hearing
that they're the police what do you
think it's gonna be
it's a robber or someone coming to shoot
you and all this happens all the time
why wouldn't you like grab the you know
your defense yeah you know and defend
yourself there there are tons of stories
like that where there's like no knock
raids with playing plainclothes cops
that's and then people are like here's a
strange man wearing regular clothes in
my house of the gun that's crazy and
then and then you end up in prison yeah
there's a bunch of stories like that
dude so and it so we have this this
story from the 18 from the American
Conservative saying under pressure by
media criticism the police department
issued a detailed statement this
afternoon purportedly exonerating itself
that's our favorite one we investigated
ourselves and found we did nothing wrong
that statement the third revision of
their official account of the fatal raid
is contradicted by multiple eyewitnesses
police now say that the raid was spurred
by an anonymous tip at the beginning of
the year indicating that Lemp was in
possession of firearms a response from
the Lemp family delivered by their
lawyer rene sandler no
using a three-month-old anonymous tip
the police sought and obtained a
no-knock search warrant on March 11th
2020 at 2:38 p.m. the police department
states the warrant was served in the
early morning hours consistent with
Montgomery County Department of Police
practice so an anonymous tip is all it
takes for a SWAT team to launch violent
pre-dawn assaults on Montgomery County
homes the press statement declared three
months old yeah
the officers entering the residence
announced themselves as police and that
they were serving a search warrant why
did they obtain a no-knock warrant if
they intended to enter the residence and
announce themselves yeah because they're
full of it according to the statement
from family members the raid began when
SWAT officers initiated gunfire and
flashbangs through Duncan lems bedroom
window in the front of the house
according to the police upon making
contact with the Lemp officers
identified themselves as police and gave
him multiple orders to show his hands
the press release reads almost as if
Lemp died from an overwhelming sense of
guilt
rather than being shot perhaps multiple
times by police it also doesn't specify
whether they'd shot or otherwise wounded
length before making contact and issuing
commands according to lems pregnant
girlfriend who is this badness Wow how
do they leave that out of the story yeah
and she said police never made verbal
commands upon either upon either her or
Duncan until after Duncan was shot and
lay bleeding on the floor Wow
the press release declares upon entrance
by officers into lambs bedroom lamp was
found to be in possession of a rifle and
was located directly in front of the
interior bedroom entrance door was he
quote found to be in possession as he
land the floor bleeding and was it lamp
or the rifle that was directly quote in
front of the interior betterment restore
the police claimed to be vindicated
because they found five firearms in the
house and because they asserted today
that lamp had a criminal history as a
juvenile I thought they said there was
no criminal history near the article
through Guardian that prohibited him
from legally possessing or purchasing
firearms in the state of Maryland until
the age of 30 though the police have a
right to kill anyone who possesses a
firearm in violation of any statute on
the books if so that's bad news for the
tens of thousands of Maryland gun owners
who are federal felons because they use
marijuana and other illicit drugs the
police department has offered a sham of
transparency they refuse to answer any
of my questions last Friday
I sent another set of questions to them
this morning prior to the latest
revision of their story among them many
people online have suggested that Lemp
was targeted for a raid because he was
helping to build a secure computer site
for people who shared his pro-gun
political beliefs is that allegation
correct did concerns about lems
political beliefs or associations
factored into the SWAT teams decision to
launch a violent raid at 4:30 a.m. did
the SWAT team or other police department
or Montgomery County officials do any
assessment of the likelihood that
someone would be injured or killed by a
nighttime SWAT raid that began with
shooting or flashbangs in Montgomery
County County police or other officials
make any effort or even or ever or even
consider making an effort to serve the
search warrant in any way that would
have permitted the peaceful voluntary
cooperation of elem family members he
was going to say that he sent these to
them he asked some other questions so
you know in the end he says the
Montgomery County Police Department
doesn't have a Fifth Amendment right to
remain silent after it kills County
residents
the SWAT team wore body cams and police
have thus far refused to release the
footage they deserve no benefit of the
doubt for this violent killing yeah I
want to see that body cam footage yeah
absolutely now I don't care what your
politics are how are you not showing
that and if the fact that you're not
makes me not believe anything you're
saying police I'm sorry yeah you wear
them for this reason right and then he
was in that video where the cop thinks
he's turning his body cam off and he
turns it on and then films himself
planting drugs Wow but I'm not surprised
that's crazy yeah dude this kind of
stuff happens all the time
so look people yeah people have been
saying this guy was developing some kind
of encrypted chat system or something
and also the cops came and took them out
hmm you know the issue I take with that
for the most part is is that enough to
kill like there's there's companies that
have encryption that have resisted
National Security Letters and been shut
down you know they're they're activists
websites that do email that have the
feds come and seize their servers would
some dude working on this warrant like
an assassination by the state I wouldn't
yeah who knows it could be it could be
an attempt to like restrain him in some
capacity that went wrong okay
like maybe he was warned already there
so no no like nominee
still doing well no no like in that was
them being like we want to put pressure
on him to get him to stop what he's
doing huh but overzealous SWAT guys were
like let her it I don't know man man you
know the issue is I interviewed an NYPD
detective and he told me as years ago he
said there's nothing more dangerous and
this is a little hyperbolic then a
scared person holding a gun and you have
these police officers who keep saying
I'm scared for my life I was scared for
my life it's like well if you're scared
go home to your mother cuz this job is
not for people who are terrified all the
time that's a good point and this is an
NYPD cop he told me a story about how he
had kid he had his gun mm-hmm he
confronted a crazy guy who had his gun
drawn and he refused to draw his weapon
and he was like cuz if I draw I'm
escalating that conflict and that guy
that weren't working in a shoot if and I
was like brah I'm not gonna draw him I
keep my hands up and I'm gonna talk to
you there's no out of this you got to
put it down eventually the guy put it
down and they took care of things now
that's that's a cop right that's
policing right and you see that's yours
historic I think was from Brazil a guy
comes in a hospital got a knife and the
guy just the cop just like sits down and
puts his hands up start talking to the
guy and there's maybe this might've been
in like Thailand or something okay but
then eventually he convinces the guy to
drop the knife then give him a hug
awesome talk about people who are brave
and heroes who actually shut these
things down yeah look III get it man I
was I was uh talking to I came over I
saw this but I was a reading story about
some cops and their mentality and when
it comes to dangerous situations okay
and I've talked to some some people who
have served like who have done law
enforcement stuff and there's like this
idea that some of them say is I'm not
going to risk my life for you I'm at
work and so there needs to be there
needs to be some kind of cultural honor
you know within this you know within
police culture I guess where it's not
about you going going to work and
dealing with annoying people it's about
you being a hero who's supposed to
defend the community that's a good point
that means you are how to why our
standard it means you are at risk
and it means that's that yes you will
put yourself on the line you know you
know to do the right thing so I can
understand it's like if if you're
walking up to a car because I've seen
i've also seen these videos man where
because they really Spidey camp stuff
for this - you know cop is walking up to
a car and then the guy in the front that
he walks up in he's like license and
registration
and then the dude reaches down and pulls
out a gun and goes pop pop pop yeah the
guys are screaming and I'm sure every
single cop has seen those two so they're
like we know it exists there's people
that just simply hate cops
doesn't matter who what kind of cop like
it could have been the the best cop you
know who walked up and would have
probably let him off but it doesn't
matter they had drugs in car or like
something something warrant right and
they're like there's nothing that's
gonna stop me from killing this cop and
getting out of here cuz fight or flight
yeah who was that guy was it Alton
Stirling was that his name yeah his car
uh how about me on the right name
let me check but there was a guy who was
a legal gun owner okay and the cop came
up to his car yeah
and said something like you know
licensed license and insurance or
whatever and then he asked me if it was
armed and the dude was like I am I have
a permit and a concealed weapon and the
cop was like don't reach for it he's
like I'm not no don't reach for this I'm
not pop Wow
I know and the girlfriend was filming it
that wasn't the guy who was in his car
but yeah there was a guy who was sitting
in his car that wasn't I got the name
wrong Phillip Phillip Castillo yeah
Lando the Lando Casteel was that it
let's see when my moon is a while ago or
recently a few years ago 2016 young
pulled over while driving in Falcon
Heights Minnesota and killed so so this
is interesting to me right I think we're
absolutely allowed to have an R
discussion about you know gun control
stuff but this is what we're getting
from it yeah they pull up to a guy who
was a legal you know gun owner falando
could steal that was his name right I
cool I don't who's Alton sterling wasn't
was another one of these okay okay was
that Maryland Baltimore all right I
think check out this story from 2018 and
I got to be honest I just google
searched red flag law yeah like killed
and then it's like all these stories pop
up where the police get a warrant to
come to someone's property and take
their guns without them knowing without
giving them a reason without serving and
they swauk up and say turn them over
like that you you got to realize like
the people who own weapons believe in
their right to own weapons and the
Constitution straight-up says you can
yeah exactly you won't have a discussion
about changing that I got no have a
discussion but if you didn't change it
you can't just show up and then shoot
somebody because they refused to turn it
over all right but they're doing it dude
there's tons of store
like this and it's crazy it's pretty
insane there's there's one this might be
it like basically here look at this a 61
year old man is dead after he was shot
by an officer trying to enforce
Maryland's new red flag law and for
Ferndale Monday morning Anne Arundel
County police confirmed the police
involved shooting happened on the 100
block of linwood avenue oh yeah yeah we
get it at 5:00 a.m.
5:15 and of course yep 5:17 according to
police two officers serving a new
extreme risk protective order a Maryland
protective order to remove guns from a
household shot and killed the man listed
on that order under the law family
police mental health professionals can
all ask for the protective orders to
remove weapons the man was identified as
Gary J Willis of the same address
officials said Willis answered the door
while holding a handgun Willis then
placed the handgun next to the door when
officers began to serve him the order
Willis became irate and grabbed his gun
one of the officers tried to take the
gun from Willis but instead Willis fired
the gun
the second offered officer fired a gun
striking Willis he died at the scene
yeah this is it this was someone saying
my cold dead hands straight up you know
cops showed up and they were like we're
taking your guys like nobody went to
grab it they fought for it and he was
like nope so I you know all of these
people these gun grabber type people's
you realize these people mean it yeah
there's a Constitution that says you
can't take it and there's there's a
serious conundrum I don't understand how
these red flag red flag laws got passed
in the first place because it's a direct
violation of the Constitution right it
makes no sense well the argument is that
the argument is that there are limits on
the on the amendments like within free
speech you know you can be sued for
slander and if you if you threaten
someone's life you can be charged with
you know threatening someone's life
right okay so their argument is that
this is if somebody has a mental illness
they shouldn't have a weapon so someone
else can flag them yeah which is all
used so what is that yeah exactly
yes it's abuse I said like the family
what it said who can do it the family
police officers mental health
professionals under the law yeah so it's
like a family member just is upset with
you or like an ex or mad at you well I
mean up as an ex would they would that
count like your ex-wife hates you yeah
like I'm wants to I wants you out of the
house and wants to go and take stuff or
something you know so you're armed and
they're like you know what I can abuse
this law yeah yeah
yikes and there are people who are not
going to give it up so this is you know
this all leads into you know what we've
been seeing recently there was there was
a viral thread where somebody went
through a list of all of our rights that
were just erased due to the pandemic and
it's a lot like oh yeah men the right to
assemble to worship XM you know free
like our expression is being threatened
you can't go outside at all and these
are all violations of the First
Amendment the government shall not be
able to do this they just did it and
everyone no one did anything so this is
what is what worries me cuz look I think
it's fair to say that the corona virus
is a serious threat it's happening all
over the world yeah you know I mean it's
like all these countries are in on it
that's it's a pandemic for a reason
right but then do we just cheer when all
of a sudden our constitutional rights
don't exist anymore I mean it is it are
they written so then it's just an
indefinite thing now or is it because of
the pandemic during the pandemic until
the pandemic ends not saying I like any
of this you're saying - is that written
is that written in there so it's written
into these laws for two years you can't
assemble no no no you can't protest like
Maryland in groups Maryland's law is
indefinite this red flag stuff no no
Maryland's do you know quarantine de
cría basically it's it's it's there's no
time limit it straight up says you can't
do these things period that's and we'll
let you know when we were VOC this law
that's not yeah they're screaming about
hungry cuz Victor Orbin gets decree
power and I'm like yeah that's a bad
thing yeah they just did it here in the
US and all these different states at the
at power Manning I'm annoyed with all
the people who go out and don't care and
ignore you know quarantine stuff because
like it's nice it's not that big a deal
man you know you don't you don't go find
in the front lines yeah you know gotta
risk your life just stay home it's gonna
be boring and there's there is within
reason how long we can we can we can do
this you know I don't think you know
that what they've been saying is 12 to
18 months two months on one month off
that kind of thing until we have a
vaccine but I don't like the idea of
just blindly trusting the government I
agree for now I'm looking all these
other countries and I'm like okay I
think it's clear to see like there's not
an international cabal
see ya till you know make stuff happen
well I never let a good crisis go to
waste so like Viktor Orban for instance
and Hungary just recently enacted a or
proposing a law a bill that would change
their their all the laws it say the word
gender to gender at birth
okay so it's like uh but that's a
political ideological move and while I
understand what they're doing and to a
certain degree I agree with like
protecting civil rights for biological
females I understand I do not agree with
like oh what's that we got decree power
because we're under a pandemic now let's
do a bunch of political agenda items
that we want to get done because no one
can stop us yeah that's messed up I
agree yeah I just saw Gavin Newsom
talking about this I think it was he's
like this is the best time to push our
progressive yeah what did what did
Clybourn say to Pelosi now is our chance
to shape things in our vision yeah these
are these dude these people are evil
dude like to just and this is the the
problem is people who want to be fair
and rational in good faith and have an
honest conversation typically don't want
to be in charge yeah but these
sociopaths who think they're smarter
than you want to be in charge so they
run for office you know they get elected
and then they start seizing power and
doing really stupid things and you know
what most people don't pay attention so
just asking why I want to vote for Tim
Poole 24 thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you